un procès chargé en émotion au tribunal
judiciaire de Tours le 7 novembre 2021
marine était une jeune maman de 24 ans
était mortellement fauchée par une
voiture au rond-point Saint-Sauveur à
Tours le chauffard en fuite se rendra
finalement à la police la famille de la
victime est venue aujourd'hui entendre
cet homme jugé pour homicide
involontaire sur place Sébastien Branger
c'est dans une atmosphère lourde et
pesante que c'est ouvert le procès suite
à l'accident qui a coûté la vie à la
jeune mère de famille tourangelle marine
et Eve sa famille brisée par le drame
espère de la justice une peine
exemplaire et de l'accusé des aveux on
peut comprendre qu'une bêtise a été
faite mais c'est le fait de pas être
rendu de passer de dénoncé qui a été
très dur pour nous d'accepter en fait et
le fait que
on attend surtout que il a été nous
disent enfin oui j'ai fait une erreur
oui c'est vrai j'aurais peut-être dû me
rendre directement on attend ça
pour rappel c'est dans la nuit du 6 au 7
novembre 2021 que madame etève est
fauché par un véhicule au niveau du
rond-point Saint-Sauveur à Tours le
conducteur prendra alors la fuite mais
se rendra à la police dans la journée en
détention provisoire depuis le prévenu
c'est présenté au procès en
reconnaissant l'effet qui lui sont
reprochés à savoir l'eau Missy d'un
volontaire et le délit de fuite je pense
que accepter l'effet d'une telle gravité
quand bien même ils sont accidentels je
pense que c'est c'est extrêmement
important et d'abord pour son futur pour
sa reconstruction pour sa réinsertion et
psychologiquement bien évidemment s'il
n'a rien de comparable avec la situation
de la famille de la victime mais il faut
aussi porter le poids d'une vie qu'il a
prise pendant toutes ces toute sa vie
les paroles victime au quant à eux
témoigner à la barre du tribunal en
lisant une lettre un moment où l'émotion
a gagné la salle d'audience une fine et
le parquet a requis 6 ans de prison
ferme au lieu des 7 ans en cours